jennifer lopez and ben affleck pack on
the pda
during a dinner date in l.a i do love
that
that's ben and jen cuddled up on their
way to dinner
check out j-lo's head resting on ben's
chest
and their arms wrapped tightly around
each other that pda
speaks for itself
[Music]
a source told et on tuesday that the
pair had dinner with two others at
wolfgang puck's marijuana on the rooftop
of the pendry hotel in west hollywood
california monday night
they looked very happy throughout the
evening and ben had his arm around j.lo
for most of the night
they arrived together and left together
the pair had previously been spending
time together in miami
and a source told et on wednesday that
ben left the sunshine state to spend
more time with his kids in la
and jlo came to la shortly after quote
they're very happy and are having a
blast
spending time together i'm thrilled the
two famously known as
benefer recently rekindled their romance
17 years after their split in 2004.
ben has been spotted visiting jen's la
home on multiple occasions recently
and the two even took a trip to montana
before reuniting in miami
it's great a source previously told et
that jen is loving the attention she's
been getting from the batman star
quote jen and ben didn't get along at
the end of their relationship
years ago but once their hurt feeling
subsided they were friendly for many
years
now that they've fully reconnected they
are having fun together and care about
each other a great deal
the two first started dating back in
2002 while starring in their first movie
together julie
i'm sorry do we know each other not yet
they quickly got engaged but by 2003
they called off their wedding just days
before their planned september ceremony
and they officially split in january
2004.
it was my first like adult heartbreak we
were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know it was like
a tough one for me of course jayla went
on to marry mark anthony whom she shares
13 year old twins max and emmy with
but they split in 2014 after 10 years of
marriage
and in 2019 she got engaged to former
mlb star alex rodriguez after
two years of dating but they called off
their engagement in april
she's really funny and amazing but back
to ben and jen
a separate source recently told et that
jennifer has been opening up to her
friends about ben
and that they're having a blast together
the source even says that the duo is
completely smitten with each other
quote it still feels like having a new
crush after all these years
you